before magnum p.i it is back Jay
Hernandez and Purdy's weeks right how
did I say right right but Purdy to be
called Purdy yeah okay first of all can
we talk about this is your first time
here in San Diego at comic-con can you
just talk about there her reaction which
was she just saw one person's goal in a
kind of mouth you were like whoa very
crazy dog lady yeah I want you to turn
around and look out that window and see
all those people they're all in costumes
they're waiting for you Jane have you
have you given her any kind of advice
about comic-con okay you were here for
suicides yeah no I just said it's gonna
be crazy
it kind of blew my mind the first time I
walked out and you know we're on stage
yeah it's like you know that's like
that's how rockstars feel when they wake
up every day pretty much an everyday
thing these people go nuts for did you
go in question no I was actually writing
your love yeah and it looked good and it
felt you know it feels comfortable I
don't have to do anything um I think I
had them coming in they were a little
squirrely at there are they yeah cuz you
had to go from that look to then
like hot dad look yeah it's a very
different you know another end of the
spectrum which is kinda nice all right
can we talk about magnum p.i and
bringing back because I do believe when
Magnum came out in December of 1980 you
were - yeah you were not on the plane so
what's it been like taking over such an
iconic role I mean for me it was I was a
huge fan of the original show and it's
just so iconic you know I mean Tom
Selleck kind of put for our red Ferraris
on the map they did I mean it's just one
of those things that it's in over
probably a hundred fifty countries
around the world so it's one of those
properties that people are aware of yeah
and I think there's gonna be a lot of
curiosity in terms
like what what our version of it's going
to be so yeah it's it's pretty amazing
there are only really two things I
remember and from my youth and one of
them is magnum p.i and Tom constantly
being the sexiest man in the world so
yeah big shoes don't worry about it you
know I get the cars so I don't you know
party you look very different from your
predecessor John Hillerman yeah it's a
whole different reboot thing do you know
someone sent me something on from the
internet which is a wonderful scary
great place to go yeah someone has
superimposed my head onto John
Hillerman's body mmm I find it guys it's
out there in his full like cocky outfit
with the Doberman it's a very strange
thing yeah he always was in khakis
wasn't it yeah you had a hole that
season - yeah you know I think they
pitched the mustache but they died when
did yeah didn't work out at first so so
what will be Higgins new flavor so
Higgins is a berry uh she's a very fun
character to play she's pretty tough
she's ex-military as well as you know
the same as the guys so she'll kick some
bottles pretty much yeah kicks a lot
about she's pretty reliable you know
she's someone you'd want on your team
kind of at the end of the world you know
their zombie apocalypse comes around yes
yeah she she likes fast cars and an
adventure and you know there's a bit of
mystery behind why she's in Hawaii so
easily to be revealed we should expect
next year we will see a lot of Higgins
here at comic-con I mean what I think
you know whether that's something who is
ooh it's just like me yeah don't women's
right can I show you something Jay yes
because we thought that we should do a
mash-up of the new Magnum in the old bag
it's amazing
yeah yeah I'm gonna save this so you can
sign it and take it and just you should
really honestly some fans you get this
yeah somebody should definitely get that
I actually somebody was like from the
camera department made a kind of a
version of that not as good as ours it
was it was rivaling that BJ not as good
as ours they printed t-shirts
I don't where's my t-shirt they hate
it's not as good as ours okay you walk
in the et booth you know do the most
that's right so many exotic cars in the
show right what are some of the cool
cars cuz I know
we're gonna go check out your robbery
yeah we're gonna check that thing out I
mean you know what's the best part about
that car is when you push the button and
it starts there was a lot of fun drive I
get to drive that one as the the for a
day as well as the California black
convertible kind of scary to drivers in
so expensive but but super fun here's
the big thing will there be any folks
from the old show popping up at any time
I know that Higgins can but there
there's definitely talk about it Jay hey
man come on you know well here's that
here's the deal is you're gonna have to
watch the show to get to more folks if
you see a certain person we're
definitely trying to make it better be
great there are talks oh yeah I like
that
oh yeah and how's Hawaii because of the
places you want to shoot Hawaii would be
one of them yes top of the list that's
for sure it's it's the most beautiful
place and like it's really one of the
characters in the show
to be honest eminence you know we we're
shooting all over a wire and I mean I'm
hoping we're gonna get two shootings on
the other Island we are yeah trust me no
I pitched I was like so you know what
are we doing that we know it's happening
you know it's just the most spectacular
spectacular place so I mean what a
backdrop I wake up and I walk out of my
bedroom and it's literally I have this
view of the ocean it's stunning you know
it's like it's like why you know that
little it's like a painting yeah you
just flew in from Hawaii so you're a
little jet-lagged yeah what will be the
differences between the old and the new
I mean you know there's the sides that
young lady right there yeah some female
energy for sure oh there was female
energy that's true actually the women in
bikinis and stuff and they kick butt
yeah she kicks butt you know that was
one of the things that was really
important to me
I was telling Peter I was like as long
as she can you know she looks like she
can beat somebody up on that everything
was yeah by the way something I just
noticed I mentioned your birthday but I
didn't realize you have it right on your
arm you have like made in 78 oh yeah oh
wow
[Music]
you use that a lot okay what's on the
agenda and will you make a move on to
the floor today today's your day go out
there and see it will you go out there
and enjoy some comic-con definitely I'm
gonna put some flat shoes on and run
around yeah take those heels off yeah
get comfortable it's gonna be a long day
here's the other thing you don't bring a
Ferrari here and not let us get in it oh
you want to get in oh of course I want
to get in the Ferrari you know put your
Ferrari I just want to look at your bra
bad boy how many see you jokes everybody
can we make it alright let's go
downstairs so everybody on YouTube vid
is watching right now we're going
downstairs where to get in the fall
right let's go